we all want to be able to play our sweet
jams when we're murdering our way
through fallout 4 it would be great to
be able to listen to the timeless thong
song when gerelds getting his freak on
and of course cheering lara croft on
from the sidelines by blasting spice up
your life girlpower lara you raid those
tombs the point is music makes
everything better and we can't wait
until xbox one lets us put those
headsets to good use support for
background music on xbox one is on
microsoft's long list of features it
wants to introduce but it may be a while
before we get to play halo while playing
halo xbox engineering boss mike abara
says in a new interview that Microsoft
is taking its time with a new feature to
get it just right background music is on
that list dobara said on the latest in a
circle podcast windows 10 will help us
as we think about what's the right way
to deliver that and we want to do it in
a way that surprises fans the Xbox one
adopted Windows 10 as its underlying
operating system with the release of the
new xbox one experience earlier this
month this has led to various efficiency
improvements and sets the console up to
be more flexible in the future Microsoft
has said if I are added that Microsoft
is thinking about xbox one background
music functionality in a similar way to
screen shots another much requested
feature that was eventually delivered
Xbox one owners can currently use the
xbox music app to listen to music while
playing a game but only with snap this
takes up a portion of the screen making
it a less than ideal solution there is
clearly demand for a better alternative
on the Xbox feedback site more than
21,000 people have voted for play music
from apps without snap it's likely that
we won't see a new update roll out until
februari as Microsoft doesn't have any
major plans for December choosing
instead to focus on keeping Xbox Live
and other network services running
during the busy holiday month what song
would you play with what game let us
know in the comments I'll come and find
me on Twitter and how not to draw I'm
Kate and remember to keep it gamespot
com for all your gaming news